structures obsolètes et coûts
d'entretien trop important pour ces
bâtiments qui datent de 1959
la décision est tombée les hôpitaux de
la verrière seront reconstruits la mgen
propriétaire du site validé le projet en
avril dernier
les pavillons d'hébergement de
l'institut marcel rivière seront donc
rasé à la place trois bâtiments
devraient être construits pour
accueillir les services de santé mentale
et le centre gériatrique denis forestier
pour un total de sont sept nouveaux lits
seulement que l'accord de l'agencé
régionale de santé avant de lancer les
travaux d'ici fin 2014
malgré le rapport alarmant de
l'inspection générale des finances qui a
récemment pointé du doigt l'endettement
des hôpitaux publics la direction
s'estime confiante
aujourd'hui nous sommes un établissement
qui n'est pas en déficit qui est juste
équilibré notre but c'est de pérenniser
cet équilibre
or on sait avec les études logistique et
architectural que si on ne fait rien on
ne pourra pas maintenir cet équilibre
donc on a voulu anticiper les
ce problème là et pérenniser un
équilibre voire dégager des excédents
qui seront de toute façon réinvesti dans
la prise en charge des patients ces
travaux vous aussi changer le quotidien
des habitants puisque le parc du château
ouvrira au public quatre entrées sont
prévues notamment du côté dans les parcs
les quartiers de la gare et du village
pourrait ainsi être relié d'ici la
rentrée
une ouverture qui s'inscrit dans le
cadre du projet de réhabilitation de la
zone gare bécane nous allons urbanisées
une partie des terrains des bécanes qui
étaient des espaces naturels c'est vrai
est donc quelque part c'est comme si
nous compensions une urbanisation de
nouveaux terrains qui sont des terrains
naturels aujourd'hui peu utilisé il sert
pas la promenade donc par la restitution
publique d'un parc boisé
le 29 juin la ville y organise
d'ailleurs un pique nique géant
l'occasion pour les verriers roi de
découvrir en avant-première ce parc de
22 hectares